how scum razzmatazz peered back so I
can't show you too much of the alien
footage for now but what I can do is
check out the alien isolation Survivor
mode which is something I'm super
excited about but yeah without further
ado let's say let's see what's this
about I think we're gonna run into an
alien this episode which makes me feel a
little tangley and Bingley inside if you
know what I mean just by like when you
fall in love except the complete
opposite something that's Amanda and I
need to collect two crew cards and
delete and lock down the stairway and I
need to eat some meat
cuz everyone loves to eat meat we do get
a lot of stuff we can make
oh look we can make all we have flames
away oh look at this
alright this is cool
I'm gonna die right away and we have
this sensor - that's cool
all right you want to fight me get ready
alright so I have some time to get ready
that's right space barrels I think I'm
scared of you I am actually terrifying I
can't really make anything though can i
I can make a noisemaker
let's do a noisemaker never in my life
have I needed to make a noisemaker I
just I would just throw my sister at
people I would have the same effect I
got it that was funny because my sister
is noisy oh so I have time to do all
this thing oh god oh god are you serious
I got ethanol that's good I can get
drunk and just go and cry hello right it
seems to be here hello dead person [ __ ]
way myself oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god I'm alive but not
for long
okay ice instigate what the [ __ ] what
happened what up I'm sorry screaming my
DC I Spit okay what is this place okay
we have an objective let's stay on clear
on the objective are you [ __ ] kidding
me
oh come on oh don't hurt me I'm Swedish
and we are pacifists he bought that [ __ ]
Oh what an idiot
all right I got a blasting cap I mean
I'm gonna make a Molotov that be honest
okay
Oh God you don't see me do you no no now
don't eat me oh that was awful
nothing not just my experience but my my
my skills I'm terrible I'm lit down
Amanda all right let's try that again
Jesus are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh I can hide in these that's great
that's very comforting to know oh god I
don't know how much I can play a little
Jesus all right well I need to do some
what well otherwise people already kinda
complain so okay
I will have 50 oh [ __ ] comfort you
really hate me don't you
nay then na he saw me do me oh so done
it oh then they're so mean
they're super mean let me get some
whiskey and I'll just get drunk are you
[ __ ] high die die die die
this is redonkulous and I'm not even in
McDonald's I don't think they have that
in space okay we're good for now
nope never never mind I'll find someone
like the map doesn't tell me [ __ ] that's
good too I was loving the map is being a
major meaning now oh my god go go go go
go go get him whoo that's what I said
damn Sam had a lamb and his name was not
Sam I need to start using this better
okay oh okay he's coming that's that's
good oh [ __ ] Molotov anything I
Oh God
all right I'm gonna die if I keep this
up I need to shape up cuz I need a man
who can make me satisfied in better
shape I'm singing degrees I'm not just
saying what I want I promise like okay
I'm just looting everything here all
right we bad but we better take it more
careful
lock down the stairwell as if I'm
capable of doing nothing but crying
right now all right bring it on Brittany
I would be amazing to do multiplayer
this I would just like oh are you
serious he got me from the bend it's not
very fair is it ah ah come on you can do
this come on bro you're with me right
now you're against me Wow
well thanks I know I suck but you don't
have to be mean okay damn all right
the noisemaker let's try that out yeah
that goes all right lock down the
stairwell delete system data so there's
there's probably like a computer that I
need to delete stuff up all right let's
be more cautious this time around
alright let's throw a noisemaker hey yo
catch idiot oh come on but what about
the noisemaker what about the noisemaker
no no no I don't like you
I don't want to kiss you no I don't yeah
very much I'm gonna pretend that didn't
happen and we're just gonna go right
away are you having fun yet oh my god
Amanda I am very sorry about all this
Amanda I'm I'm sincerely trying here
okay they are so powerful or maybe I'm
just really bad that's that's that's
probably it me being really really bad
all right why don't we guy here I didn't
make a noise make it this time around I
don't even have enough stuff to do it
you see there
hello oh come on
go go go go go go go in the butt go into
but ha you can't touch me I got my
master degree in Sniper II watch me nose
couple 360 from a tree while lucky
I just want to go home and cry for the
big pack of ice cream cookies and cream
it's that too much to ask Oh got it
uh Shh what is that where is it coming
from Oh
they're so sneaky they're super sneaky
that's like double sneaks and wow you're
gonna come back bro no I need a
noisemaker man and I need it bad no no
you don't know me you don't know me you
haven't met me or taking me out on a
date or anything oh I'm a laugh
hey soon a miracle or sky start done I
had no choice
I had no choice okay let's pretend that
didn't happen
all right let's keep moving keep on
moving on keep on moving now
all right I think the bad part is over
the hard part is is yet to come
no don't don't do me a favor
because I don't want you in my life okay
I think we're getting close to the
computer breasts and I collect the
Smurfs to flame through fuel so there
might be hope in my life after all there
might be hope all right are you the
computer that I need to you're [ __ ]
kidding me
oh it's truly do you see that you know
there's medication for that
I'm just saying okay let's not go
underneath that one what am I supposed
to go up on today
come on that was not me that was Ed
Garrett screaming I don't scream like a
girl
hey man you look good he looks happy he
looks very I would rather be him right
now why do I keep checking the map it's
not like the map is gonna do anything
all right this has to be the stairwell
I'll walk down the stairwell come on
it isn't simulating Oh God don't come in
here please
come on hi go away please
all right this is this what is this oh
it's one of these okay match the signals
got it uh okay
nailed it did I do it whoa we locked
down high fibrous it was amazing I've
seen from one direction was here would
be like that was amazing whoa
this is awesome I like this game-mode
this is really cool they're really
sneaky it really feels like you're being
hunted man woman alien
what is this the next step maybe in this
nightmare I don't know man
like what it's okay we have a lot of
stuff let's do some crafting and stuff
noisemaker
all right let's make a noisemaker cool
what are you doing here mr. duck yeah
who do you think you are okay
this is kind of spooky
I don't know what I feel about this okay
you didn't see me now
so far so good all right
once a [ __ ] always a [ __ ] that's what
I used to say hey here are you [ __ ]
me Jesus go away
thank you flamethrower you're my best
friend man I don't know how to tell you
there we go alright uh how do I restore
power 1 2 3 go 1 2 3 go 1 2 3 go
whoa what'd I do
escape in the elevator I would love to
but I only did one of the objectives
okay let's calm down let's calm down and
rethink our situation we're dead okay
let's escape that I don't trust anything
in this game I love you you love me
let's go home and watch Glee just
kidding that's lame I'm a cool cool man
what about these noisemakers I don't
know
am i safe in here um I don't think so
he could saw me no [ __ ] way mama just
killed a man and I got against his head
my trigger now he's dead
come on I thought we were cool in here I
don't have any flamethrower left oh come
on I might as well just go out and cry
but boy stoned crying oh god hold that
oh god what was that oh god what was
that
badass I failed
I felt empire to collect ah God
well what that was a good run I'd say
that was a pretty good run whoa that was
awesome
I made me pump man I saw it's so cool I
love that
alright press I'm gonna have to have
that episode there I'll see you in the
next one we'll be part of the the
original planet playthrough we'll go
back to that one let me know if you want
me to do more of these I had a lot of
fun but yeah that's all for me for now
thank you very hitting a like button I
really appreciate it you bros showing
your support that's very cool thanks to
say guy for letting me play this early
and as always stay awesome